to those
destroying these huts in the himalayan
forests
they're unwanted pieces of wood and
cement
but to the bakarwal and gujjar the
muslim nomadic tribes who lived here
their home at least for six months a
year
as they move between the forests and
mountainous pastures with their herds of
goats and sheep
we are yet to recover from the shark we
have been living here for generations
we are now worried for our livestock and
our children
i tried to plead with the demolition
team but they threatened us with a rest
and a fine some in the tribe received a
notice from the local forest department
saying their homes were illegal a few
days later
people arrived to tear them down
the himalayan region of kashmir is
controlled by india and pakistan in part
but
claimed by both in full last year
india revoked the region's special
status imposing restrictions on movement
and enforcing a communications blackout
critics say the government wants to
change the demographic of the muslim
majority region
and is carrying out the demolitions to
do that
they want to dislodge people gradually
from this place
throw them out make them homeless in
their own territory
so settle non-kashmiris
indian is there and that will facilitate
their agent off completely hinduising
kashmir
but local officials say they're only
following court orders
and that more than 60 000 people are
illegally squatting on the land
in india traditional forest dwellers are
usually protected by law
and tribal leaders and kashmir say that
should extend to
them
last year when the special status was
repealed the government published an
advertisement
that they were going to implement the
forest act law
in the region but the reality on the
ground is different
the government is working against us and
people
are suffering under pressure from the
government to move from the forest
and from encroaching cities some say
their traditional way of life
is becoming too difficult
we live in fear that we may face the
same fate as the others
we keep on thinking day and night that
our homes may be demolished
where would we go for generations
they've led a nomadic lifestyle
but that could soon become a thing of
the past
alex o'brien al jazeera